joseph murat a été entendu pendant plus
d'une heure à la barre cet après midi et
ces déclarations contredisent
complètement celle de son frère joseph
affirme que l'accusé lui a dit à
l'époque connaître la victime de vue et
l'avoir croisé dans le quartier ce que
nie depuis le début jean pierre murat
autre élément très important son propre
frère a des doutes sur sa culpabilité
je me suis posé la question parce qu'à
force d'être interrogée par la police
je me suis posé plein de questions
du coup
la famille de christelle mairi à
semble-t-il le coeur plus léger en
sortant de ce quatrième jour d'audiences
plus on avance plus c'est flagrant
c'est flagrant et ça fait peur parce
qu'on voit qu'il a terrorisé beaucoup de
monde autour de lui
et j'attends le verdict
jean pierre murat a quant à lui continué
à tout nier en bloc en accusant même son
frère d'être inventeur